il est président de la république il
assume d'abord et avant tout les tâches
qui sont celles d'un président de la
république et il n'a pas à se laisser
troubler par tel ou tel commentaire par
telle ou telle parution tel ou tel livre
tel ou tel débat autour de la parution
de sony même si ces débats sont par
ailleurs parfaitement lui qui parle dans
les livres il n'est pas assez venez
venez mule pas on n'a pas se laisser
troubler par les débats légitimes donc
et je peux y participer si vous le
souhaitez sur le bouquin oui oui mais
mais il est présent la pluie qui doit
assumer pleinement et totalement ses
fonctions il a donné une orientation il
ya plusieurs mois de cela en disant je
dirais aux alentours de mi décembre
si je suis candidat ou si je ne suis pas
candidat
rien de ce point de vue là n'a changé
c'est à mi décembre que le président la
république actuel dira s'il a choisi et
pour quelles raisons s'il a choisi
d'être candidat on n'est pas candidat
juste pour le plaisir il bet on est
candidats qu'aux quelque chose et peut
espérer qu avant la fin de l'année
absolument persuadé que dans le contexte
actuel il est espéré que tout d'un coup
il a l'air dé retrouver ou trouvez pas
ce que vous regardez aussi les choses
dans la durée des niveaux de popularité
et je fais une grande différence a aussi
ses expériences entre ce qu'on appelle
la popularité est ce qu'on appelle une
intention de vote
c'est pas tout à fait de même nature
s'est pas tout à fait de même nature oui
bas dans les sondages d'intentions de
vote qui a un sol déjà mais aujourd'hui
les parents 94 d'ailleurs ouais enfin
bon on peut toujours voir les choses
dans tous les sens donc aujourd'hui la
dispersion dad
je finis sur le président la pique je
lui avais si j'avais un conseil l'idée
puisque vous dites je suis proche c'est
vous avez donné monsieur le président la
république une indication au 15 décembre
c'est 15 décembre ou d'un retour du 15
décembre que vous ferez connaître votre
choix si j'avais un deuxième conseil à
lui donner
c'est qu'une candidature doit avoir un
sens on n'est pas candidat pour être
candidat ou on ne l'est pas pas candidat
s'il peut dire on refuse d'être candidat
il faut effectivement refuse il faut il
faut aussi que c'est un sens on ne peut
pas dire que donc il faut qu'ils aient
un sens à sa est un sens qui est pas un
sens personnel qui est pas hélas ans par
l'histoire par rapport à la france y
compris par rapport à la gauche ou par
rapport à quelqu'un dans sa famille
politique
et bien si on se présente c'est parce
qu'on pense que quand on peut continuer
à s' à l'ombre de choses mais surtout
qu'on peut mener des politiques qui
soient des politiques qui apporte au
pays quelque chose de nouveau
on n'est pas candidat pour rééditer on
n'est pas candidat pour refaire on n'est
pas conduire pour réparer on est
candidat pour construire quelque chose
ait quelque chose de nouveau dont la
france peut avoir mais il ya pas mal de
gens à gauche qui commence à lui dire
ben
c'est peut-être que justement pour le
bien de la gauche voire pour le bien de
la france on se ferait mieux de renoncer
je sers et des gens intéressés faites
sûrement des gens très ça c'est à
d'autres très intéressé si je regarde si
je regarde indépendamment de l'homme
françois hollande
si je regarde l'intérêt de la gauche
puisque certains je le comprends pense à
l'intérêt de la gauche
l'intérêt de la gauche c'est que
françois hollande soit de nouveau le
candidat parce que c'est celui quelles
que soient les commentaires du jour du
lendemain ou de la veille
c'est celui qui a le plus de capacité à
rassembler la gauche
quelles que soient les critiques quelles
que soient les insatisfactions même si
je regarde s'ils ont aimé mais les
déceptions sont une chose il faut les
regarder comme tel il faut les analyser
comme tel il faut les respecter comme
tel il faut leur apporter des éléments
d'explication et du monde espoirs il
s'agit pas de dire les français sont
heureux ils demandent qu'une seule chose
non il faut regarder la réalité en face
mais moi je compare la politique c'est
pas simplement de regarder quelqu'un
c'est aussi de comparer aux autres et
quand je compare aux autres candidats de
gauche
je n'en vois aucun qui soit mieux placé
que françois hollande pour rassembler au
premier tour et évidemment si ces
objectifs rassembler au deuxième